- [Voiceover] Exercising can
make you a happier, chiller,
more sexually aroused person.
But it can also be
expensive and confusing.
Good news.
You can do these twelve,
totally free exercises
pretty much anywhere, anytime,
using nothing but your own body weight.
So sorry, you're out of excuses.
Pushup.
Put your hands under your
shoulders, and keep your feet
hip-width apart.
Keep your body in a straight line
from the back of your head to your hips.
Don't tilt your head or lift your butt.
Keep your elbows in and close to your body
throughout the movement.
Plank's like a pushup,
except you don't move.
Your body should be in a straight line.
Tighten your core, tuck your chin,
look at the floor, keep
your feet hip-width apart.
Squeeze your ass.
And breathe.
To up the ante, do plank taps.
Keep your body still as
you tap your left shoulder
with your right hand.
Then tap your right shoulder
with your left hand.
Carry on, alternating between hands,
and getting fit as (censored).
Glute Bridge.
Lie on your back with your feet
hip-width apart, toes facing
forward, and your knees bent.
Contract your abs and
push through your heels
to lift your hips off
the (censored) floor.
There are four lunges you need to know
to change your life.
Side lunge.
By keeping your chest
up, shift your weight
through your mid-foot and heel,
while lunging as low as
your flexibility allows.
Don't get (censored) sloppy
and let your knees travel
forward past your toes.
To do a reverse lunge,
start out standing straight.
Step one foot backwards,
keeping your front knee
at a 90-degree angle.
Keep your chest up like
you give a (censored)
and distribute your weight
evenly between your feet.
Allow your back knee to
lightly tap the floor,
and push through your
front heel as you stand up.
Spider lunges sound scary,
if you're afraid of spiders.
But they're not.
Start at the top of a pushup position.
Bring your right foot to the
outside of your right hand,
landing with a flat foot.
Bring your foot back to plank
and repeat on the other side.
Keep your shoulders over your hands,
and your hips in line with your body.
You've got this dawg.
Jumping lunges aren't for pussies.
Keep your front knee at
90-degrees and lunge as low
as your flexibility allows,
without the back knee touching the floor.
Seriously, don't let it touch.
Keep your torso vertical as (censored),
and your weight distributed
between your feet.
Jump to switch your feet.
Land softly.
Single-leg deadlift.
Keep your back flat, your core tight,
and your weight evenly
distributed in your planted leg.
Raise one leg behind you,
hinging at the hips with
your toes pointing down.
Don't be an (censored).
Bend only as low as
your flexibility allows.
Pull yourself back to stand,
using the hamstring of your planted leg.
Keep your head neutral, keep going.
Squat.
Put your feet somewhere between hip
and shoulder-width apart.
Turn your toes out as needed,
keep your chest tall,
and look ahead and slightly up.
As you bend, be sure your knees track
in line with your toes.
Squat only as deep as
your flexibility allows.
You know how deep that is.
When you're feeling advanced,
it might be time for the squat jump.
Squat until your thighs are
parallel with the floor,
with your chest up.
Hold your arms straight as you squat,
and push them behind
your back as you jump.
Exhale as you jump as
high as you (censored) can
and land softly.
Walkout.
Keeping your legs as straight
as your flexibility allows,
and your back flat,
bend at your waist, and
place your hands on the floor
in front of you.
Keep your core tight as
your walk your hands out
to a plank position.
Push your hips as high as possible,
and press your heels into the ground
as you walk your hands back in.
It's about the god(censored)
journey after all.
Not the destination.
You look fitter already.